of extreme violence said said if you
want to write in laâyoune
we have to get to work will need to
invest in hawaii in pipe to day we first
of all propose two of the regime
defend intractable it will be our
unique wi fi hotspot capacity  choice
of ottawa
youpi 9:30 a.m. will provide use they
all offer us teams
every you been welt evry sit in from the
sncf tax at the height of real madrid at the
top of a studio the living with war
die stimme the editorial flanagan way  of
disappearance and girlfriends machines apple
inc on line up in the means case
full city
this means that work as 34 saint pie x
of these world in the simple life you work
is not the wild west no charge of
mac and rival economy se  are
indeed complained field at the top
when surely after tactics
then lying africa in a world which has
two potato is at fault a billion in it is going to
happen in europe
we will defend our borders with
the help of the new european
border guard agency of  coast guards
guarantee you the solidity of
European defense the European defense industry
must be
innovative
this is why we will propose before the
end of the year the creation of a
European defense fund to
actively stimulate the  research and innovation
it is time that we the citizens the
institutions the governments
all take responsibility for building
this europe and building it with
care i call on all the institutions
of the european union
and each of our member states to assume
more  responsibilities